Peak TV is here to stay with networks
and streaming services already lining up
exciting new series for years to come
looking ahead to next year we're already
excited for a slew of shows with huge
stars on both sides of the camera and
intriguing and interesting premises
ready to bring new perspectives to the
small screen get ready to make plenty of
room in your cue because these are just
some of the many TV shows you can look
forward to watching in 2018 Black
Lightning
The CW is taking on a more mature
superhero with black lightning
a former masse vigilante who spent years
keeping the streets safe starring Chris
Williams as Jefferson Pierce the show
will follow his close calls fighting
local gang the 100 and how his wife
convinced him to quit for the sake of
his daughters after years of safely
operating as a high school principal
though Jefferson has eventually called
back into crime-fighting as the 100
takes over the town again he'll
eventually enlist the aid of his
daughters Jennifer and Anissa who take
on the identities thunder and lightning
black lightning reportedly won't
initially be set in the arrowverse with
the rest of the CW's superhero shows
which offers up a lot of creative
freedom for the series to establish its
own tone and pace once this show lands
on screen January 16th the Alienist T &
T is going period for their next
prestige drama the alienist this
psychological thriller starts Daniel
Bruhl as dr. lászló Chrysler an expert
searching for the person responsible for
the demise of several boys in New York
City the cast also includes Luke Evans
as his partner and Dakota Fanning is a
woman with hidden information related to
their search Chrysler will stop at
nothing
leads me to the darkest pal think of it
as mine hunter with a late 19th century
twist the alienist lands on the small
screen
January 22nd ap bio following his turn
in It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia Len
Howerton snoo his series puts him in the
lead
titled ap bio the sitcom comes from
Saturday Night Live alums Seth Meyers
and Lorne Michaels Howerton will play a
philosophy scholar who loses out on his
dream job and goes to work as a high
school biology teacher realizing he has
a room full of honor roll students at
his disposal he decides to ask you
teaching biology and instead use the
kids to his own benefit the show is set
to debut midseason on NBC it is a very
tough reflection of how things are the
ballot of Buster Scruggs the Coen
brothers are scheduled to jump on the
Netflix bandwagon in 2018 with the
ballot of Buster Scruggs
which follows six stories about the
American frontier with each chapter of
the anthology focusing in a different
plot Tim Blake Nelson will portray the
titular singing cowboy in the first
episode with other a listers coming in
to round out the rest of the season
stars including Stephen root Ralph ina
sin' James Franco and Zoe Kazan westerns
have a complicated history on the small
screen but if anyone can do it it's the
guys who brought us True Grit in No
Country for Old Men Castle Rock Stephen
King stories are always prime fodder for
adaptations and Hulu is looking to jump
back in the game with the 10 episode
psychological thriller Castle Rock the
anthology show which will follow
different sets of characters from kings
novels we revolve around the fictional
main town featured in King based movies
like Stand By Me Cujo and needful things
Aundrey Holland is set to star as Henry
a death row attorney with a unique and
complicated history and the cast is full
of people who should be familiar to fans
of adaptations of King's work including
Carrie [ __ ] Spacek and it's bill
skarsgård the show is rounded out by an
ensemble that includes melanie lynskey
jane levy in scott glenn with king's
properties at peak popularity right now
this small screen homage to his literary
world is bound to be a hit
cloak-and-dagger multiple Marvel series
are set to hit your screens in 2018 but
free forms cloak and dagger looks like
one of the most exciting the show stars
olivia holt is tandy bowen AKA dagger a
teen raised with the ability to emit
light daggers who is forced to adapt
after a storm uproots her life meanwhile
Aubrey Joseph appears as Tyrone Johnson
aka
a teen who can engulf people in darkness
the trailer teases the series bigger
connections to the MCU ending with
Tyrone standing on top of the rocks on
corporation building and the evil entity
featured in other Marvel properties with
potentially bigger implications along
with their grounded story we're excited
to see this superhero pair in action
Cobra Kai The Karate Kid has already
gotten a big screen modern remake but
Cobra Kai promises to be something else
entirely
this new show set to premiere on YouTube
red will reunite original franchise
stars Ralph Macchio and William Zabka
to show what happened to the pair after
the events of the initial 1980s trilogy
taking place more than 30 years after
the fateful events of the 1984 all
valley karate tournament the new series
will see Johnny looking for redemption
by reopening the titular dojo and
reigniting his rivalry with Daniel while
Daniels now successful in life he's
struggling to find balance without the
help of his mentor mr. Miyagi who was
played in the original film at the late
Pat Morita the pair will address their
past and present frustrations through of
course karate get ready to pencil a
YouTube red subscription into your
budget because this is a series you
won't want to miss untitled animated
Deadpool series the Merc with a mouth is
taking over the silver screen again when
Deadpool 2 hits theaters in 2018 but the
character will also get some small
screen action courtesy of an animated FX
ax series from Donald Glover Glover who
made his MCU debut over the summer and
spider-man homecoming is set to write
executive produce and service coach
showrunner on the series alongside his
brother Steven the adult-oriented action
comedy isn't expected to Hue too closely
to what we've already seen in theaters
though FX had John Landgraf said the
tone of the series will be really
different from the movies and the goal
is to make something distinct from Ryan
Reynolds take on the character and
remember hugs not drugs Jack Ryan
although the Jack Ryan movies have been
hit or miss in theaters this 8 episode
Amazon series might breathe new life
into the Tom Clancy character the show
will feature John Krasinski in the title
role which was previously held in the
films by Alec Baldwin Harrison Ford Ben
Affleck and Chris Pine and the show will
follow the up-and-coming CIA analyst as
he unravels a pattern of terrorist
communication that could threaten the
whole world the rest of the cast
includes Wendell Pierce as Jack's boss
James Greer Abbie Cornish is Kathy
Mueller and others so count on this to
be an action-adventure for the ages
Crypton there are already quite a few
superhero shows on TV right now but
Syfy's Krypton looks like a different
take in the crowded genre set on the
titular planet 200 years before the
birth of Superman it shows how the house
of Elle was shamed and ostracized the
series will follow Superman's
grandfather's se gal on his quest to
bring hope and equality to Krypton
turning a planet in disarray into one
worthy of giving birth to the greatest
superhero ever known fans can expect to
see a lot of familiar elements from the
comics including the villain Brainiac
and Segel's unlikely human mentor Adam
Strange origin stories are always Fe but
with Superman's ancestors at the fore
here this should be an otherworldly
adventure worth watching mosaic HBO is
going experimental for their upcoming
Steven Soderbergh series mosaic which
follows the aftermath of a homicide
Olivia Lake of Fame children's author
goes missing after romance blossoms with
a mysterious stranger but this won't be
your typical mystery series through a
mobile app viewers will be able to
create their own adventure as they delve
into the twisty plot viewers will get to
choose their point of view and which
story to follow with each choice
building on the others enabling the tale
to be told in a multitude of different
ways and ending in different conclusions
the app will give viewers a few months
to play with it before Soderbergh
unveils his official take on the story
in a six-episode series in January of
2018 if soda Berg's name and HBO's
innovative method of presenting the
content aren't enough to get you on
board it also has some big stars
attached including Sharon Stone Garrett
Hedlund Beau Bridges and Paul Reubens
experiments are popular in the age of
peak TV and this seems like one that
could succeed in a big way new warriors
the new warriors may not currently have
a TV home but they're expected to hit
the small screen at some point in 2018
Marvel's first comedy series was
initially set to debut on freeform but
it was eventually pulled from the
network which wouldn't have been able to
fit it on its schedule although the fact
that freeform dropped this series is
definitely worrisome new warriors is
still setting up to be a lot of fun the
series is set to bring the very popular
Squirrel Girl to live action with mulana
vine troupe taking on the role other
stars include Derek feeler is mr.
immortal Jeremy tardy is 9 Thrasher
Calum Worthy is speedball Matthew Moy is
microbe and Kate comer is debris the
series follows the six after mention
young people as they deal with their
powers while trying to make a difference
in the world even if the world isn't
ready and since they live and work
together the sea
is sure to provide quite a lot of
tension and comedy untitled
the purge franchise has done very well
on the big screen and now it's coming to
TV love house television is set to bring
a purge interwove an anthology show to
USA and sci-fi next year franchise and
show creator james demonaco has said
that he wants the TV series to spend
more time delving further into the
characters motivations emphasizing a
side of the purge that the movies have
not had a chance to explore demonaco
believes this will make purge night seem
even more intense as people are more
familiar with the characters and
understand their full arcs although we
don't know who'll star in the show yet
this seems like an interesting take on a
popular horror series rise Friday Night
Lights meets Glee in 2018 courtesy of
nbc's rise based on the 2013 book drama
high-rise follows Josh Radnor as Lou a
high school English teacher who works in
the theater department in a Rust Belt
town in Pennsylvania he decides to
reinvigorate the school's drama students
through their performance of the hit
musical Spring Awakening the cast also
includes Ali Carvalho who will play a
student named Lillet and Shannon purser
who has a recurring role as a student
named Annabel Rosie Perez plays the high
energy drama teacher Tracy while Rami
and Newton will play a mysterious
independent student who works at the
school's lighting technician this is us
may currently have the monopoly on NBC's
tearjerker slot we're onboard with
another good cry every week let's dream
big the Romanovs madman creator matthew
whiner is taking on Russian royalty with
his Amazon anthology series the Romanovs
which follows people who believe they're
descended from the famous Romanov family
the last imperial dynasty to rule Russia
the Romanovs were eliminated by
revolutionaries but some speculate that
one daughter Anastasia survived the
attack as many as four the episodes will
be set in the United States while four
will be set and filmed abroad the show
has an all-star cast on board including
Diane Lane Aaron Eckhart Isabelle
Huppert Christina Hendricks John
Slattery Jack Huston Amanda Peet Corey
Stoll and Paul Reiser given the
impressive work winder delivered on Mad
Men and the anthology approach he's
taking with this series the Romanovs
sounds like an intriguing new take on an
old mystery thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]